today's draft we're gonna have some fun
i got my golf shirt on just for this we
are going to do a draft of the nfl
personalities for whom we'd like to
caddy chris gets the trivia question if
he gets it right he gets the first pick
and here we go chris tom brady and
peyton manning met 17 times during their
career that is regular season in
playoffs combined
which of them won more games against
each other in the playoffs peyton
manning or tom brady
oh
i'm pretty sure
oh
i'm going to go
with
peyton manning
you are correct trick question because i
would have brady i assumed brady payton
was three to two three to two peyton
regular season brady was nine and three
but in the post season peyton was three
and two cuts against that narrative that
brady wins when it counts the most and
peyton chokes when it counts the most
three and two against brady in the
postseason i don't know that sunday
makes it four and two
sunday doesn't count all right who would
you like to caddy for you get the first
pick
well somebody that kind of likes like is
close to home for me all right and it's
just you know i've only heard a few
stories but i'd like to hear all the
stories at some point i'm gonna go with
lawrence taylor i mean lawrence taylor
is famous for his yeah
first off he used to stop by our house
and steal my dad's golf clothes right on
the way to the golf club so at 3 am
at 3 am he might have been out all night
he'd call the house that's a very famous
story and the the sims household
happened probably about uh two or three
times in like a two year period but
either way uh just whether the stories
i've heard about my dad when you do play
with them of course you're gonna have
some fun smoke some cigars have a few
drinks you know the conversation
speaking crazy uh he might throw a golf
club or two into the woods he might
break him over his leg every now and
then you're gonna get everything who
knows michael jordan might come play too
they went to north carolina so you never
know the type of crowd you might get in
your foursome but lawrence taylor would
be my first pick uh as for all the
reasons you can speculate a lot of
energy a lot of fun and it's a big
strong human being crushing a little
white ball
yeah speaking of little white uh
substances he's got more than cigars in
that bag potentially but that's a
different story
he'd have been my first pick without
question he'd have been my first pick i
was
so hard you were going to screw that
question oh my gosh it would have been
it would have been spectacular it would
have been great um you know and now it's
wide open you can go so many different
ways um
i'll go bill belichick i want a caddy
for bill belichick i just want to be
around the guy i want to be in the
presence of greatness all-time greatness
if a little bit of it rubs off on me so
be it and you know and at times ever you
know it's like if he doesn't want to
converse much that's fine whatever you
want to do bill it'd just be an
experience to be around to watch how he
operates see how he thinks glean
anything you can from just being around
the master because i'm sure he he
applies the same brain power to golf
that he applies to football we know he
golf that's right so yeah i'd be more
than happy to carry the bag i i would
would uh be scared to death any time he
would ask me any questions about what
clubby should use my response would be
whichever club you want to use and uh i
would just kind of sit back and take it
all in
i know you but you know the the thing
that could happen with belichick in one
of these rounds too is you think it's
gonna be awesome and you better soak it
in and then you get done with 18 holes
and you go damn you only said nine words
in all 18 holes i didn't i didn't learn
anything he didn't say
or anything i just said a bad word there
i went i just said i'm sorry
i can't believe it i can't believe it
just came out of my mouth okay yeah i
can't either i can't either
okay here we go my next pick okay and
this is like an odd board all right i am
an idiot let me apologize
let me apologize on behalf of our
friends at sky sports that the folks in
the uk and ireland have you may just
want to leave that message at the bottom
of the screen up all the time i need to
get out of my house i need to get back
in the studio in a professional
environment that's what i need to do i
really do
you may get a chance to when you have to
go get a job at a real place of business
i i might you're right i might be fired
there so all right here's my my next one
just because i would love to see this
guy trying to hold the golf club
would be chuck benarrick all right
chuck manero all right
with all his fingers that go all the
different ways and everything like that
i mean i don't know how he would do it
either way i would love to hear old
football stories about him
tackling jim brown and whatever and all
those other frank gifford stories all of
that but i don't know it just when it
came to my mind or the great
personalities he's got a great
personality let alone he's got some
really messed up fingers that go in all
different directions
there are plenty of guys though that
would fall into that category from
tory holt to who's the guy on nfl
network who's the guy on nfl network
with the finger that the one willing to
get us down is that william again
analyst the guy who the guy who played
years ago i can't remember his name um
brian something i don't know
he's got brian baldinger yeah right yeah
he's got one that goes straight south
jim harbaugh's fingers are all over the
place i don't know how these guys hold a
golf club the ones that have had the
capsules broken inside their knuckles
and i don't know is there is there no
way to get those repaired or is it just
like a badge of honor that like you like
to freak people out with your fingers
that go in 50 different directions i
don't get it but if that was
i think it's more like trouble to get it
fixed at everything than you realize and
i think people will just they let it be
because i don't think it's a guarantee
you're going to feel like a spring
chicken if you do fix them i know
there's a lot of people that have had
issues after they fix it that's why they
just say i'd rather let it be
i'm not going to show you my middle
finger per se but my middle finger see
my middle finger on my left hand i see
that a little of that that's that is
from playing basketball and stoving it
against the ball you know you reach your
hand out and it hits your finger and
having it swell up about 50 times that's
the end result that's not from so you
can imagine if you get that jacked up
finger just playing pick up basketball
how bad your fingers can get screwed up
playing a real sport like football and
getting your fingers twisted around all
the time all right next up for me
i i got some other good ones i'm gonna
i'm gonna sandbag you on one of them
though i'll go tony romo uh he's the
best golfer that the nfl has ever
produced he's he uh he's not that far
away from being good enough to be on the
pga tour so you know my job's a hell of
a lot easier is a caddy if the guy's a
great golfer he can't blame it on me
he's going to be great i'm just going to
stand back and let him do his thing and
he seems like a funny guy and he you
know have some wise cracks and hang out
and have a good time with tony romo but
you know
the winner he's going to be the winner
so i want to carry the bag of the winner
how hard is that i i i hear you i love
being with tony romo i got a chance to
walk around with him last year lake
tahoe tahoe for two holes on the golf
course you know he's just got a great
way about him he loves football so he's
definitely willing to go into all of
those conversations and yes he's a
natural hit in the golf ball just like
the next guy that i'm about to talk i'm
going to go with aaron rodgers i mean
you know why i'm going with oh
yes right because i'm going to be fanboy
i'm going to be fit here mr rogers you
want to towel here mr rogers would you
like me to clean your golf ball here mr
rogers would you like another drink here
mr rogers you want to chug a beer with
me i can beat you in that i might not be
able to beat you in the golf competition
uh but i i mean come on that it is my
favorite player and rogers can really
hit the golf ball i mean he really can
every bit as impressive as tony romo
when i was sitting there watching him in
person had a birdie and then an eagle in
the two holes i walked with with aaron
rodgers but yes you know roger's the
thing i really respect about him he's
very honest and real he's gonna keep it
that way he's deep thoughts i mean you
can get into a lot of deep conversations
with them as we've seen there's been
some very sensitive subjects you know
that have gone on in the world and in
the nfl the last few years and aaron
rodgers hasn't been bashful about
talking about it so that's my kind of
guy and that's why i'll go with a-rod
all right that one's good and that's not
a surprise i'm surprised it wasn't your
first pick i really could have screwed
you up if i had made it my first round
pick that would have hurt you because
you've been squatting on aaron rodgers
here's one i've squatted on the whole
draft
i
would want to hold the bag carry the bag
and be around chad johnson slash chad
ocho cinco for two very important
reasons number one
he's gonna have plenty of great cigars
in his golf bag which is good i assume
that caddy gets to partake number two
he's one hell of a tipper isn't that
what it's ultimately all about he left a
thousand dollar tip recently at a
restaurant i figure he has if i do if i
do my job if i smoke my cigar with him
if i don't turn green from it and we
have a good time he'll give me a nice
big tip when it's all said and done so
uh mission
accomplished as much money as you can
always looking for the money
yes
yes yes why not
oh and you definitely have some laughs i
mean he is hilarious and he's gonna say
and do some things that are gonna make
you cry you'll laugh so hard and you
know really if you really want to have a
great time with chad ocho cinco you
bring along terrell owens along with
them those two are like peas in a pod
they go at each other i've spent some
time with them on numerous occasions and
had a blast with both of them they're
like
uh two brothers who were always
bickering and i'm better you're better
you stink at this so that would be a lot
of fun though ocho cinco is one of my
favorite players that i've ever been
around
who else was on your list real quickly
oh i went with like you know bill walsh
i went with john elway i had belichick
uh i had bubba smith remember old bubba
smith the actor from the miller life
commercials and i just thought man i
mean it was part of my childhood
especially him being a police academy
that'd be a guy i'd like to see hold a
golf club and just have a talk with uh
that was about it um o.j simpson also
made my list there's a certain subject
i'd like to pick his brain about for 18
holes
uh okay uh interesting choice there
i had i had john randall on my list just
because he would paint his face and he'd
just be crazy and he'd be talking more
trash than what we saw and heard on
sunday from peyton manning and tom brady
plus he'd do all of his research he'd do
everything he could to get inside the
head of the people he's competing
against i had parcells on there i'd want
parcells
if you were caddying for lawrence taylor
yeah that would be really good uh you
know again my my dad really rarely goes
through a week without bringing out a
bill parcells saying he would have a lot
of wisdom and things to talk about he's
a great storyteller so that would be a
good one for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports